[Music]
i was born deaf
my parents found out when i was five
i did go through speech therapy
i can speak some hi like that as an
example
around five percent of the world's
population is affected by some form of
hearing loss
while hearing aids are helpful for some
they're ineffective or
only partially effective for many deaf
people
and cochlear implants are expensive and
require an invasive surgery
[Music]
recently inventors around the world have
been working on new ways of letting deaf
people experience
sound
something we don't remember but all of
us had to learn how to use
our ears so when we were born our brains
didn't know how to interpret all these
volleys of spikes coming in and
eventually it became
just the perceptual experience of
hearing
and this is exactly what happens to
people with the wristband they start off
saying oh there's something buzzing on
my skin
and then after a while they simply hear
with it
baby
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what the brain is really good at doing
is taking in information
and putting together a story of what's
going on out there but the surprising
part
is it doesn't care how it gets that
information
so we're used to eyes and ears and nose
and mouth and fingertips and so on
but it turns out that you can get the
information in there a different way and
the brain will figure it out
this is what's known as sensory
substitution
so in my neuroscience lab we got
interested in this topic of
sensory substitution and whether we
could do that for people who are
deaf so we built a vest that has
vibratory motors on it
so this is the uh the vest that we built
and the vest capture sound and turns
that into patterns of vibration
on the skin of the torso sleep
work and deaf people
could get so good at this that they were
able to understand
spoken words
so we ended up shrinking that down over
time to a wristband
and it's listening to the world and it
has vibratory motors
all down here and this is spread in a
spectrum
so that you're actually feeling the
sounds from low to high
which is exactly what your inner ear
does your inner ear picks up on sounds
of the world
breaks it into low to high frequencies
and ships that off to the brain we're
doing the same thing but we've
transferred the inner ear to the skin
so that was a car engine starting and i
could feel
i could feel the vibration on my skin of
the engine and of course since it's
mapped from low to high frequency
i feel it go up and down i feel it
spatially as well as the amplitude of it
on my skin
philip was one of our first participants
when we were testing this out some years
ago
and so philip actually wore a very early
prototype of this
and it was very life-changing too
they gave me an example of the first
product they had and i started crying
when i first used it
it was great i was able to feel and
understand so much stuff that was
happening around me
i know when i have it on i do have this
connection
i feel more connected with my family i'm
able to recognize words like when they
say i love you and things like that
i'm also able to feel emotion in
people's voices and i think we should
all have that
okay so philip you ready i'm gonna play
some sounds and then you see if you can
identify them
i like those knocking on the door very
good here we go
oh dog barking yep
[Music]
oh that's the car horn yeah very good
very good
[Music]
oh yeah that's definitely the piano
i love music without this i'd have to
you know turn up music really loud
and put my hands on everything to feel
the vibrations
i don't want to have to touch everything
especially with covid
but with the wristband i can feel
[Music]
everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
okay so now we've stepped out into the
road to test the wristband in the wild
and to
see if philip can tell when there's a
car coming down the road
yeah yeah yeah okay let's see if we can
hear another one
yeah this guy is feeling a real-time
feed of data
the question that i've been asking as a
neuroscientist is can we actually make
it so that
we're picking up on different kinds of
signals and experiencing a new kind of
reality
we brought in a blind participant and
put the vest on him
and he could tell where everybody was by
feeling where people are around him
we have 70 other projects in development
right now
for feeding in new kinds of senses to
people so not merely substitution but
addition of senses so for example being
able to detect
infrared light or electrical fields
or the movement of the stock market or
twitter sentiment or what's going on
with your drone as you're flying it
around where you're actually
feeling the picture roll orientation and
heading of your drone
on your skin whatever you plug in the
brain will figure it out and it turns
out if you plug in new
senses as long as it's relevant the
brain will figure out what to do with
those senses all the information is
sitting there but normally we're blind
to it and it is possible
to take in this kind of information and
add it to our repertoire of what we
consider
reality
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
you